Hey Travis, how are you?
Doing well? How are you doing?
Doing good. Oh, you're in office today?
I am.
Any specific occasion or just like that?
No.
Two.
My camera wasn't working very well, so I had him drop off an external camera. And I also have a board meeting after work in town. So I figured I'd come up for the day and spend the evening here as well.
Okay.
So Crystal is working from home?
More work, right?
Kris still working from? Ohh, OK. Is she gonna join the call?
Yeah, yeah.
Yep, I assume so. I was just on another meeting with her, so she might have had some follow-on questions coming out of it.
Okay.
So it seems like a busy day for you. A lot of meetings and obviously the board meeting would be big.
A different board of a volunteer on a nonprofit.
Okay.
So part of the board of directors for that. So that's the after work meeting that I'm on.
Okay, okay.
But yes, very, very busy for the last year, I think.
Yeah, you have been a lot busy and thanks for putting the time and efforts that you carve out for this meeting. So this is really appreciated by all of us because the inputs from your end do mean a lot of lot to us. So in terms of expansion, Travis, are you seeing any...
expansion senior team. When I say expansion, I'm talking in terms of work, not in terms of resources, like more customers coming in or something like that. Hey, Crystal.
Hello?
It's even. As much new business as we're getting, we're able to take care of some of it ourselves. So right now it's kind of washing off as even. We're going to continue our tech expansion. So what we can service personally, but at the same time, we're also
Yep.
We.
Taking on stuff that we can't service.
Um, at about at the same pace right now, I would anticipate that that increases a little bit, but...
I think we're staffed good right now with luckily with Crystal's help and all of your guys' help with onboarding and training and moving to ConnectWise, we're well in position to handle more work. We're just hoping that it doesn't come in one humongous wave.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I have already informed Crystal and I earlier informed as well in the previous calls. Any help that Crystal needs from me, I would be more than happy to jump in and help her out in maintaining the boards and everything so that she is able to gauge the work and everything. So I am at your disposal, Crystal.
Whenever you like, you can ping me and I would be able to help you out. Yeah, so good to hear that the business is expanding and everything is going good. Okay.
Thank you.
No.
So let me share my screen and let's proceed with the agenda. Updates, performance metrics, holiday calendar, ITPD offerings, way forward and recap. So Atlas started with Marco 9th March. He has been grasping well. We do have a...
Bi-weekly call set up with both Adler and Agam on different times and both.
issues, but moreover, what the better part I see, I see them discussing more on process point where they are asking Crystal, like if this is a new thing, how that's going to be done or anything. So that's going good. We haven't observed any issues, so that's a good point.
point. Yeah, regarding Adler, he has been working well. Obviously, he's off for this week because that was a planned early from a previous month itself. He has been wrapping up quickly and the training on connector wise manage is going on in this week, Crystal. So.
I guess Adler is missing it, but he knows ConnectWise very well. So I guess he would only need some time in doing some process related training, which I should, which I think that should not take much time. And when is the transition happening?
Travis, you said like, is this week only or only the training is happening this week?
All that was tabled. Migration was backdated for a month. So.
Roughly mid-May will be the transition date. Bad thing is we're ready for it. The good thing is we'll be able to iron out all the different processes that need to go into there.
Okay.
Oh.
He's not gonna miss any connect to my screening.
Okay, so I guess a lot of work coming on Crystal's way because a lot of challenges with the new processes and everything. So that is something that is going to be big and huge for Crystal. But I'll tell you Crystal, like having that thing in ConnectorWise.
Yeah.
It would be pretty easy and smooth for you. The process would not be difficult because you would just have to set the status and everything. Obviously, when you set the status and everything, obviously there would be a follow-up email that would be sent or something like that. And then we can do an automation on it, like as soon as the status is set.
there can be an automated email that's sent out to the user or the dealer, whatever it is. So I guess that should be done and I can help you out in that, in setting that up. And we can test that as well. So do we have a test environment, Travis, in order to test all these things or we can test it on?
A live environment as well.
Just test right now.
Okay.
But we do we do have it live. The team has been working and clicking through and figuring out different things. They got together last week and put together a list of questions. And I got I spoke with Crystal yesterday. We're going to start airing out all those questions. So then each time when they're going in there each week to play around and keep it refreshed.
for next week's or next month's transition, we should be able to get all questions answered and everybody's going to be comfortable with the system in general.
Okay. In software development, I do know that there is a term for it.
But yes, test cases, we do call it test cases where we put in a lot of situations and then we have everything around, like if this step is being done, what should be the outcome and what should be the desired outcome? And then next column we have what is, what are we getting? And then we raise it and fix it. So.
These are kind of test cases that we are doing. So that's good. We are fully testing it out. So that's a really good step that we are doing so that no issues come out in mid-May. So I guess, yeah, nice strategy. So this looks good, I guess. Crystal, you want to say anything?
Been bombarded with question.
Nope, no questions necessarily just yet. We're formulating our list and then getting answers as we continue playing with it. So that's good.
And how are you coping up with Manish?
I was ready for this week and I'm like, all right, we're gonna do this. And then Travis told me yesterday, like, well, we're gonna table that. And I was like, I feel relieved, but now a little disappointed and frustrated because I was ready for it. So it'll be good. We'll have more time to play with it.
There was a little bit of like, oh my gosh, we got to get all these things. Like, what is it going to look like? And we had the team together while Travis was out last week. And it was only going to be an hour meeting. And I was like, sweet, we're going to have this hour. We're going to go through all of these things. It'll be great. And we got in there and got one thing done. I was like, oh.
We're gonna have a lot of hours of playing with this.
Yeah, that happened.
Yeah, so in generally in this kind of testing, it does take a lot of time. I have done this testing on my end as well. So I know how many test cases we build and there are a lot of issues and then we need to fix. And when we do is that as a team, so yeah, a lot of challenges do pop up in.
Yeah.
then it does take a lot of time, a lot of hours, actually. Yeah.
Yes, yes. I think we were in a meeting. Thankfully, everything is in just a nice place right now where we were able to, as a group, get together. I think it was like 3 hours where all of us were like, all right, my brain hurts. I need food. We need to take a break. So it'll be good to have those where we can take a little chunk now not feeling the
Kip.
The pressure of it's coming next week.
OK, that that's really good.
So it'll be good.
Yeah, and obviously, I guess, Travis, if it if things do not shape out by mid-May, you are going to push it by end of May or mid-June.
It will be in me.
Yes.
It, and finally.
I don't think I'm going to be able to push it out any longer. Luckily, this one's not on me. This is on our resources for it. But IT does not like that we're extending a server past its serviceable life.
Yeah, I got it. I understand. And then KPI numbers from March are waited for Agam. I'm not I'm not concerned about Adler because he just started in March. He might have only 10 days of data because till 20th he was just learning and post 20th he was working so.
I don't see any see any good numbers for him, but yes, we are going to see that for April.
Yeah. Yeah. My focus was on learning ConnectWise and figuring out what I had to do for this week. And of course, now that is postponed, I got to go backwards for the whole team and get all the KPIs also. So it's not just your team that I've been delayed on. I got to get it.
Yes.
Crystal, as well.
Yeah, okay.
But the good news is I know how to do it in ConnectWise now, so we'll be we'll.
Yeah, connect-wise, it's getting numbers is easy.
Yeah, I'll just, it'll be an adjustment to what we're measuring versus, right, how many emails did you send, which is.
Yeah.
Not a good measurement of anything, but...
Yeah, but utilization definitely will help you in seeing how the engineers are utilized, what the correct utilization looked like, and how we can utilize them better. That would actually give you a better planning because as of now, there is no time tracking. We just...
Yep.
Go by assumptions, so even if an engineer or a technician is putting in like 5 minutes or 15 minutes.
We do not have that accounted for, but later on we would have that accounted for and then we can see overall this process is taking time because the engineer is utilizing these time. So I guess that would be a good measure, but we'll wait till June and July and then we'll see how.
Yeah.
The shape of the matrix, yeah.
Yep.
Reid.
Moving on next, like performance metrics, these are till Feb, so we already know about this data. And for Adler, we are waiting for March. So we'll update that. Apart from this, no upcoming leaves or holidays are coming in.
And the next holiday that we are coming is in 25th May. Any other thing apart from this? Any other holiday coming in before that?
Yeah.
I don't think so. I don't ever keep track of holidays.
Probably not good for me.
Okay.
Let me, let me look.
I'll pull up ADP quick.
I don't think so. I think Memorial Day is the next one.
Yeah, I think I think that is true.
Yeah, because we follow a US calendar and that's why it's is a thing that I know.
Yeah, following the same calendar.
So yeah, so 525 will be our next.
our next day off, Memorial Day, and then nothing until Independence Day, so 4th of July. We'll have the 3rd off.
Yeah.
The day before.
Usually in US, we do not have any holidays in the first half. In the second half of the year, we do see holidays like every month. There is a holiday that pops up like in May, then July, then September, and in November and December.
The fun last half of the year. It's just party all the time. I like it.
Yep.
Same here. I also like it.
Okay.
But Travis does not like it, like he does not track the holidays, so I guess he is more workaholic. He likes to take less holidays.
Yep, yep.
Okay.
We just gotta do both, right? We just work until they're like, oh, hey, tomorrow we don't have to come into work. Sweet.
If...
It's like a present.
Yes.
Yeah.
And talking of present, like I was watching one of the toons, like I just to and they say like you should enjoy the present and that's why it's called as present.
Absolutely.
Exactly.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. And that's one from a very famous movie. I do not remember. I think it's from Kung Fu Panda, I guess. Yeah. Yeah.
Great way to look at it.
That's a good one. It sounds totally like Kung Fu Panda.
Yeah, but that that line has stuck with me for years, and yeah, that's a good line.
Agreed.
Yeah, Vishal, you want to add on anything? You want to present anything?
No, I'm all good. It's just like that. I'm just struggling with my camera. So my apologies for that. No, I think I'm all good. Happy to see team is working well and contributing as per Travis and Kris explanation. So happy to see that.
Yeah.
Okay, I guess we are good. I'll give you your 15 minutes back so that you can have more meetings on ConnectWise.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
Thanks.
Okay. Thanks, team. Have a great day, Ed.
Thank you so much, Javid. Thank you.
Kip.
Right.
Thank you. Have a great day.
Like.
Thanks. Bye. Bye.
Bye.